coming up on Star Talk special edition
it's all about sleep and we learned what
it is why we need it how it impacts our
perception of time and how it is that we
actually go crazy when our head hits the
pillow as we drift off in
Slumber coming up on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
I got Chuck Nice my co-host Chuck hey
what's up Neil all right Gary O'Reilly
hi Neil all right and this is a Star
Talk Special Edition all about
sleep
sleep Gary what have you put together
today well sleep Neil we all do it um
some better than others but
why and why have humans not evolved to
do without it I've been asking that my
whole life
now we're going to get somewhere right
what are Cadian rhythms and what are
chronotypes what actually defines a good
night's sleep um what's it going to be
like sleeping in
space uh there is so much to understand
so let's go grab ourself an expert Neil
if you would like to introduce our guest
and just because you sleep at night
doesn't make you an expert all right we
need a real expert we need a real expert
we got Dr Matt Walker Matt welcome to
start talk
oh it's a delight and a privilege and I
have to say I'm a little intimidated by
the intellectual horsepower that's on
display across all three of you but I am
um it is it is such a privilege you mean
me I I well let me be agnos profess
University of California Berkeley yes
I'm applying it um oh no don't be fooled
by that all the accent um yeah my um I
think someone last week suggested that
I'm if I were any more stupid you'd have
to water me twice a week so just be
warned love
that that's very funny so you're
professor of neuroscience and psychology
at University of California Berkeley
that presumably means you have an
official appointment in two departments
is that correct I do indeed and you're
the founder and director the center for
human sleep science at UC Berkeley with
Center spelled c n t is that correct in
my notes here that is very correct how
evil of you clearly clearly somebody's
somebody's not getting enough sleep to
spell
correctly oh there are going to be so
many instances of my faas that you'll be
able to point out and say this guy must
be on for three hours of sleep idiocy so
uh inbound and author the bestseller why
we sleep unlocking the powers of sleep
plus dreams and you're you're Ted talker
why wouldn't you be after all that and
you are the host of the boringly titled
the Matt Walker podcast what's up with
that I know you know the team around me
we had one of these Retreats three or
four days bashing around titles and I
think the The Innovation there was
stunning The M Walker podcast um you can
see that we're a creative bunch in this
domain so deeply deeply
at the end we're just going to agree
that you need more sleep okay that's
what's going to happen here so what I
want to know why do we need sleep at all
I see that as a shortcoming of the human
brain if aliens came and they just
watched us just lay down and beat semios
for onethird of Earth's rotation they'll
wonder what's wrong with these people
isn't it stunning and when you think
about it from an evolutionary
perspective it makes no sense because
first were not finding food we're not
finding a mate we're not reproducing
we're not caring for our young and we
still were vulnerable to predation so on
any one of those five grounds but
especially all of them as a collective
sleep should have been strongly selected
against in the course of evolution but
the fact that in every species that
we've studied carefully even
evolutionary ancient old species every
species seems to sleep or have something
like sleep what that means is that sleep
evolved with life itself on this planet
and then has fought its way heroically
through every step along the
evolutionary path which must mean that
sleep is absolutely vital and in fact
it's once been said to your point Neil
that if sleep doesn't serve a critical
set of necessary function
it's the biggest mistake The
evolutionary process has ever made way
I'm going I'm going with the ladder
ladder sorry man after my own heart
choke no no no just let's get the
honesty out on the table put it out up
there right out front please please um
but we now have a huge collection of
science that suggest that um why Mother
Nature did not make a spectacular faux
power in creating this thing called
sleep so do worms sleep when you say
animals you not talking about just
vertebrates or mammals you mean all
animals yeah all yeah so even earthworms
which are so old from an evolutionary
perspective they have states of activity
and inactivity and if I were to show you
on a on a video it's really quite
telling that they seem to have it may
not be sleep we call it lethargus in
these species it's the kind of fancy
earthworm way of saying you kind of you
kind of look like you're asleep we can't
ask you the question yeah you know but
yeah it could it could be it could be
they're just lazy you know that's right
they are lazy at very predictable times
across the 24-hour period right uh but
despite that you know when they put
their feet up who knows what they're
watching maybe it's um earthworm Netflix
I don't know but they do it in a very
stable predictive way I I hate using
this term but you'll know exactly what I
mean do higher level animals require
more sleep than lower level animals it's
a very interesting question which is can
we understand the functions of sleep
across philogyny across different
species and it's been
fishlyn
we got cats that can do that that bat
has nothing on my cat man I'm
sorry all animals that end in at can do
at least 19 hours a day yeah it seems to
seems to be but but then if you look at
um you know elephants for example they
sleep maybe just two to three hours and
you think well is there a correlation
between size then absolutely not there
is no correlation is it about the size
of the brain nothing to do with the size
of the brain is it about prey versus
Predator and your status on that
hierarchy not at all wow is it about the
complexity of your nervous system a
little bit but not much omnivore
herbivore um carnivore does that protect
no it doesn't um if you are temperature
regulated Thermo regulatory or you're
not so warm blooded or cold blooded yeah
warm blooded cold blooded but we're
starting to understand that it's
actually a complex set of all all of
these different things metabolic rate
does seem to be predictive um and such
that if you have a higher metabolic rate
you your idea would be well then you
need to sleep more to sort of restore
that it's the opposite higher metabolic
rate you need to stay awake for longer
so you can get in enough calories to
support your higher metabolic rate and
so it's a very complex question but to
your point no there there is no simple
correlation that explains the vast
variance of sleep across species so
we've heard things about sleep rhythms
and maybe leading the pack there's
circadian rhythms could you just shed
some light on that I think Chuck had a
question about that too yeah well no I
just I I was wondering if like the
earthworms had a circadium rhythm
because that's one one of the defining
uh attributes of sleep is the fact that
you actually do it at kind of the same
time in the cycle of the day you're
absolutely right so that's one of the
way so let me start with what Cadian
rhythms are and sort of break the the
term down um Circ sort of around
approximately and Rhythm we all know
what that term is so C that's the same
Latin word when Circa
18 yeah something okay cool exactly and
then you've got um Dian from the Latin
derivative of d so in other words it's a
it's a rhythm of around or approximately
one day why is it not precisely one day
well when we've done studies where we
take human beings there's there's a
famous study with a professor Nathaniel
um cman and um and they went off down to
Mammoth Cave I remember the study in
America without they just lived whatever
day they wanted right and they just
lived and they wanted to see what
happens to their sleep sleep weake
rhythms do they just Abandon All timing
and the answer was no no they stuck to a
very close timing but it was close to 24
hours but it wasn't precisely 24 hours
when they cut themselves off from the
outside world specifically the most
predictable thing on this planet which
is that since the dawn of time unless
you want to correct me the sun has
always risen and the sun has always set
and it's set in that 24-hour rhythm MC
nature and when they decoupled
themselves from that rhythmic signal the
body still kept its 24hour Rhythm almost
it was just a little bit laggy and it
ran about 24 hours and about 30 minutes
and now we figured this all out in big
studies and it's about 24 hours and 12
minutes that we run a little bit late if
we're disconnected from the outside
world that's why I always want to sleep
an extra 30 minutes after the alarm
alarm clock that's why please do that
please do that um or better still remove
the alarm clock and just add an extra
half hour
exactly yeah but if I were to disconnect
you like they did with in Mammoth cap
you just drift forward in time you keep
adding on about 50 minutes so that's so
it's a that's why we Define it as about
24 hours but beautifully when we're
living in the real world we have cues of
that 24-hour period like light but also
feeding at certain times those cues
which are what we call zeit gers from
the German term time Giver act like
little fingers to pop out the dial on
your wristwatch and reset it to 25 24
hours each day so you don't Drift But
coming back to Chuck's question that's
one of the ways that we Define sleep in
species where it's hard to sort of place
electrodes in or place electrodes on
their heads so we can look look to see
do they do that activity and inactivity
state in a 24-hour predictable Rhythm
yes also another one is is it reversible
because that's what differentiates it's
one of the things that differentiates
sleep from death which is that when an
organism goes into this state of
inactivity yeah yeah I was going to say
it's not the only one don't worry but if
you prod the earthworms then they seem
to come back to life as if they were
absent this waking state right right so
when you've got circadian rhythms and
it's trapped into a 24-h hourish cycle
by obviously
clinical experiment what happens if
you're an early bird or a night L and
you call those Chron correct they're
early people and they're they're they're
morning people and they're night people
so so how are we I mean is that
disruptive or is or is that is that just
you know some people have software
uploaded that does that other people
have this yeah are party people and then
there is everybody
else plus Gary the the term for your
brain is not software it's wetwear we
have different wetar okay sounds like
I'm scuba diving but I'll go with that
so isn't it isn't it a strange thing and
we are we are um defined by our
chronotype and our chronotype by the way
whether you're on evening type morning
type or somewhere in between it's about
a third third split across the
population um it is not your fault it is
genetically determined largely and there
are at least 22 different genes that we
now know will dictate your chronotype
destiny it's gifted to you at Birth you
can't really change it very much
unfortunately but how does this fit in
with that strange sort of circadian
rhythm I just told you everyone has but
these chronotypes as I said it's uh
there are essentially three types and
it's genetically detered mined um what's
interesting about those is how it
changes what I just told you about the
24hour clock face the scadian Rhythm I
told you that we have a rise where a
dianal species were active during the
day and then were asleep at night active
during the day so how does chronotype
fit into your innate Cadian Rhythm
chronotype dictates were that sort of
sine wave were that oscillation of
rising activity and then the lull of
sleep were that sits on the 24-hour
clock face so we all have a sadrian
rhythm but if you are a morning type
your Peak activity will arrive earlier
on the clock face whereas if I'm a
neutral which I am I I'm just going to
sit somewhere in the middle and then the
you know the party people uh um saying
anything yeah their peak of activity
won't start happening or Rising until
the afternoon everyone has a 24-hour
rhythm where that Rhythm sits on the
clock face and is positioned is dictated
by the chronotype does that make any
sense so the chronotype is like a dial
that sets the place where you fall on
that way yeah you
I
exactly hey Star Talk fans you know
there's been a lot of talk about
comedians making up stories and then
passing them off as real life
experiences and that's why I'm inv in
you to get tickets to the taping of my
comedy special on November 17th and 18th
and fact check the hell out of me the
special is titled Chuck Nice just smart
enough and hopefully I'm smart enough
not to lie but there's only one way to
find out and that's go to Chuck KNC
comic.com and get tickets to Chuck Nice
just smart enough at the midnight
theater in Manhattan on November 7 1th
and 18th two shows each night and
remember facts don't lie but I just
might so Matt I I I get it you can
describe what you already see in us but
scientifically what I really want to
know is what the hell is going on inside
of us while we're
asleep and we now know that and we know
it from a broad perspective in terms of
Hope brain activity and we also know it
right down inside of a cell itself in
terms of the expression of genes and
everything in between I mean we have you
know sliced and diced sleep in all sorts
of ways but I'll just give you some
highlights upstairs in the brain it is
stunning it is a spectacular display of
electrical symphonic ballet and trust me
if you saw it you would be stunned and
in fact we've even extracted these brain
waves from the sleeping brain and we've
converted them into sound files so and
you could it's it's amazing so what
happens is that when we're awake we have
very fast frenetic activity your brain
wave pattern or patterns sorry I should
say are going up and down many many
times per second maybe 50 60 times per
second as you start to fall asleep those
brain waves start to slow down and when
you go into the deepest stage of what we
call non-rapid eye movement sleep so you
have two main types of sleep non-rem
sleep and REM sleep non-rapid eye
movement sleep rapid eye movement sleep
and nonm sleep you can split it up into
light nonrem deep nonrem when you go
into deep
nonrem something incredible begins all
of a sudden hundreds of thousands of
brain cells all decide side to
synchronize in their firing in unison so
they all fire together and then they all
go silent together and they all fire
together it's almost like this Mantra
chant and it produces the huge powerful
deep slow rhythmic brain waves that have
riding on top of them these incredible
bursts of electrical activity called
sleep spindles and so this is it's
stunning and then you go into REM sleep
and then the brain becomes once again
frenetic in fact if all I had was your
brain wave activity Neel during REM
sleep and I was in the other room and
you're in my sleep center I could not
tell in the bed are you awake or are you
in REM sleep in fact some parts of your
brain are up to 30% more active when you
are in REM sleep and dreaming which is
stunning and then downstairs in the body
gosh it as you go into deep sleep it
provides almost the very best form of
naturalistic blood pressure medication
that you could ever wish for your heart
rate drops your blood pressure lowers
your immune system kicks into high gear
upstairs coming back to your brain the
there is a cleansing system that starts
to pulse and it flushes out all of the
toxins so it's literally a power cleanse
for the brain at night there are so many
stunning things these are just a few
that I could regail you with all right
well listen I got to go take a nap so
my work here is done
J you so you sold me I'm good to go
given that these things are happening
Matt is the brain able to improve mental
health is it having an effect on things
like dementia it does it radically
Alters both what we call your cognitive
functions so learning memory and also
your emotional and your mental health
processes so in terms of emotional and
mental health we've done a lot of work
we do a lot of work at my sleep center
on this firstly sleep and particularly
dream sleep seems to provide a form of
almost overnight therapy where it will
take difficult painful
experiences and it will essentially act
almost like a nocturnal soothing balm
and just take the sharp edges off those
painful experiences so that you come
back the next day and you don't feel as
bad they don't feel as as painful
anymore and so it's not time that heals
all wounds but it's time during sleep
and specifically dream sleep that offers
that emotional convalescence as it were
um so that's one of the the mental
health benefits go there was a great
quote by the way Joseph um e Joseph
Cosman an American entrepreneur he once
said that the best bridge between
Despair and hope is a good night of
sleep and that's exactly what we've
discovered in the laboratory your other
question Gary is very interesting about
cognitive function and Alzheimer's
disease what we have discovered is that
so there are at least two toxic proteins
underlying the disorder of Alzheimer um
one is amalo protein beta amalo protein
and the other is called to protein and
yeah what we discovered is that during
sleep and particularly deep sleep at
night there is this pulsing sewage
system it's called the glymphatic system
you you have one in your body it's
called the lymphatic system in the brain
it's called the glymphatic system and it
only kicks into high gear during deep
sleep and it it sort of washes out all
of the metabolic detritus of the day two
of the proteins the toxic proteins that
sleep will wash away every night if you
are getting enough of it are these two
Alzheimer's proteins amalo and Tow
protein and that's why we found such
strong links between insufficient sleep
across the lifespan and your risk for
developing Alzheimer's disease so from
that perspective it's a a form of almost
you know good night sleep clean is there
any work being done to figure out um how
you might induce that artificially or or
is the cleaning of this amalo plaque by
your brain not significant enough that
it might be able to ward off um
Alzheimer's uh all together but the
mechanism itself is that something that
we could replicate artificially to
either Aid in that process or just do it
fantastic question and in fact it's a
question that we have addressed we
started to develop a Technology based on
something called transcranial direct
current stimulation it sounds like the
of Science Fiction more your stuff than
than mine but I promise you it's it's
not you apply electrodes to the head and
you insert a small amount of voltage
into the brain and it's so small you
typically don't feel it but it has a
measurable impact and if you apply that
stimulation during sleep during those
big powerful deep slow brain waves when
we get this cleansing um you can amplify
the size of those deep sleep brain waves
and we can almost for example double the
benefit um that deep sleep brain waves
give to your memory the next day and so
that would mean a short you can you can
hyd a shorter sleep to make you feel
like you had a longer sleep well we
don't know it's we don't know if by
improving the the the size of these
brain waves does that reduce your
overall sleep need and if we could to
your point um Neil it would suggest that
we're almost able to buy compressing
sleep through increasing quality it's
almost as though I am you know I'm I'm
sort of like Zip filing sleep I just
compress down your sleep need by
improving the quality and it's a short
ter I mean that would be spectacular we
haven't found evidence for that yet but
we have found the ability to manipulate
this brainwave activity and we've now
since uh split it out into a startup
company to to develop the device what
intrigues me the way you describe the
different parts of the Sleep Cycle the
Sleep the sleep session um I hadn't
thought about this before this moment
that if you sleep for less time than the
full allocation or you're on some travel
regimen where there's time zone shift
and whatever you can get some sleep
serving only some parts of that
portfolio of need leaving out other
parts of that very portfolio so are
there effects I mean you mentioned
Alzheimer's but overall why can't I just
sleep a little longer later I got to
stay up and pulling all night or tonight
it's a it is a very interesting question
can you essentially you know catch up on
sleep when youch missed it catch up and
we say that all the time right you know
just I gotta catch up on some sleep you
know I've got to uh I've got a tough
week this this week but at the weekend
don't worry I'm going to catch up
unfortunately many of the processes of
sleep not all of them in truth but many
of them do not work like the bank so you
can't accumulate a debt and then hope to
pay it off at some later point in time
sleep in many ways and learning in
memory is is a good examp example is an
all and offing phenomenon meaning if you
don't sleep within the 24 hours after
learning those facts you can lose the
chance to consolidate and hit the save
button on those memories so you end up
forgetting the information rather than
remembering it yeah I read the uh
abstract on a study that was talking
about that and what they did was they uh
measured the cognitive retention of
people who sleep right after learning
something as opposed to those who didn't
and oddly enough if you want to do well
on a test go to bed study and go to bed
it's it's but supposed you go to sleep
during the class does that help well you
know
what is in my C I teach a large course
here of about five or 600 uh students on
campus uh the science of sleep and at
the start of the semester I say based on
what I know regarding the benefits of
sleep on learning in memory um it's the
greatest form of flattery for me to see
people like them not being able to
resist the edge to strengthen what I'm
telling them by falling asleep in the
class so feel free just to e and flow
through Consciousness throughout my
course I'll take absolutely no offense
Matt is there a connection between
dreams and time because there's we've
had this question pop up before on
previous episodes but without a a sleep
expert we we all saw the Christopher
noan movie uh the Inception right which
embedded time frames with inur and Matt
may have had a part in that did you have
a part in that I can neither confirm or
or deny that but um what I'm about to
tell you is is very um uh congruent with
the movie so time is is so fascinating
when it comes to sleep because it's a
total Paradox on the one hand you lose
all sense of time meaning that if you
fall asleep on a plane you know let's
say you transatlantic flight um when you
wake up what's the first thing that you
do typically you look at your clock and
you say you know how long have I been
asleep why didn't you weren't you able
to track time in your sleep no so you
you have you've lost your sense of time
during sleep at one level but then the
second level is that when we fall asleep
and we go into dream sleep there
something different happens with time
and we've got a neural explanation that
I'll come on to but what is different
about dream sleep is that you can get
what we call time dilation and this
comes on to the movie Inception where at
the first level down five minutes in the
real world is maybe 50 minutes in the
first level of the dream and then it
maybe it's five years in the second
level and then maybe it's 50 years in
the third level now we don't actually
have these levels as it were we really
just go into the dream state but it it
is fitting because when you go into
dream sleep and here's a good example
let's say that you have a snooze button
and your arm goes off and your snooze
button is for three minutes so you hit
it and you go back to sleep and you go
back into the dream that you are having
and then the alarm goes off again three
minutes later but you could absolutely
tell me no that wasn't three minute I
was dreaming for what felt like 15
minutes and so time is stretched and
dilated which means that yes Inception
light you have more time as you go into
dream sleep why would this be if you
look at rats running around a maze as
they learn the maze the memory centers
of the maze code the maze so it's sort
of
like if you were to listen to the brain
cells as it's learning the signature of
the Maze and then scientists have let
those rats sleep and then they've
listened back into the firing of those
brain cells and what's stunning is that
when you go into REM sleep unlike
non-rem sleep where things speed up in
REM sleep it goes
from to
BU it's about 0. five times it's like
taking this podcast and hitting on your
podcast player play it at 0.5 times for
me that's what dream sleep is actually
like and maybe provides an explanation
for why we have time dilation and why
you can create beautiful movies like
Inception and now at what level at what
level does it go
to well the one that I'm most worried
about is the one that
goes alen I'm trying to be
fitting
CCT all right Matt how about
premonitions because I've got into this
before about a premonition I've had but
um do we have the ability to see into
the future while we dream or quite
literally are we just dreaming no the
answer is no no no no really we want it
to be true books are written about it
it's in it's in religious texts ask the
oh Neil I'm so glad you are in the world
um well at first glance you're right and
then if you look at some of the data you
start to think ah uh is he right because
there are some cases where people and
this is what people will tell me say
look the FBI has a documented person who
two days before called them and said
look there is going to be um
unfortunately a plane crash it's going
to be uh you know this specific uh line
and it's going to crash in this state um
it's going to crash here in the United
States and they think you know it's just
crack part and the FBI should arrest
that they just think this this person is
is out of their mind and then lo and
behold you know two days later and now
that person seems like a culprit and
they find out that it's not how is that
that seems deeply prophetic when that
person then tells you during the
interview I had this dream it was a
dream that told me this was going to
happen it felt so real and now I've just
seen it happen and I want to go back to
my phone call and you think okay there's
got to be something in this well this is
where there are lies damn lies and
statistics because if you think about
firstly we have about four to five REM
Cycles every night and let's just say
that for every REM cycle we only have
one dream it's probably not true but
let's be conservative in our calculation
so that's about four to five dreams per
person per night across the current six
billion human beings so if you do eight
eight eight billion right and let's
assume that of those you know seven are
at the stage of development where they
actually are dreaming so I become
conservative again that math that
mathematics as we would say if you
calculate it means that it is highly
probable by just statistical chance
alone that someone somewhere on the
planet tonight is going to have a dream
that turns out to have some degree of
predic ition of something that will
happen in the world tomorrow it is just
statistical chance unfortunately Neil
you're a gem you're absolutely right
again and we remember the hits and not
the misses right do you call up FBI
every time you have a some kind of crime
premonition you know it's I had a dream
that someone killed my wife and it has
not happened what is on what is
happening why I can't get away so much
trouble with the good
lady
yeah so you've bust that myth by
statistics and damn lies in my opinion
Matt so um when we enter a dream state
and we sleep is there a point where we
are entering into a psychotic state by
all definition yes because when you
start to dream you begin to see things
which are not there so you're
hallucinating you believe things that
couldn't possibly be true so you're
delusional you become confused about
like the monster chasing me that feels
immensely real and you know ask your
heart rate and it will confirm that very
much you know um and so and you lose
your sense of time place and person so
you're suffering from disorientation you
have wildly fluctuating emotions that we
call being affectively labile and then
how wonderful you wake woke up this
morning and you forgot most if not all
of that dream experience so you're
suffering from Amnesia what does
actively l mean means unstable almost
pendulum like in an unpredictable manner
where you're just unstable so it it's a
very labile State and in that way you
know across all of those five things
hallucinating you're delusional you know
you you and you're
amnesic if you were to report any one of
those symptoms when you're awake to me
you know you would be seeking serious
psychological psychiatric treatment but
for reasons that we're now only just
understanding it seems to be both a
perfectly normal biological and
psychological sake but you are
essentially entirely psychotic when you
drink nice to
knowed well it's good to see that things
don't change when I go to sleep welcome
you know you invite a guest onto the
show and what they end up doing is
accusing you of becoming
psychotic I got a question in zero
g um you know I think of a nice cozy
night's sleep it's a a fluffy pillow
nice cozy comforter blankets uh in zero
g your your body doesn't lean in any One
Direction you just float there so does
you think your brain know I we have you
can ask astronauts this of course but
I've NE I never thought to do so um does
your brain have to have some sense of a
gravity Vector while you're asleep do
you think yeah like like your inner ear
for proper for proper dreaming
fascinating uh question and you know
we've done some work with with NASA um
with sleep and it's it's a it's a really
important challenge for a number of
reasons but firstly what we found is
that that gravitational Vector as you
described it isn't thankfully hugely
influential such that any one particular
stage of sleep or your entire sleep
becomes um un ungenerated as it were not
the word but um it it's not necessarily
a problem there however there are some
other problems the first is just simply
pragmatic that if you are floating
around and you're asleep you're going to
start bumping into things you're always
going to be waking up so firstly you
have to terab yourself against this yes
strap them in on exactly floating by you
know the people who are working the
night shift the typing way there who's
that oh it's Gary floating by you
know and the people who snore you know
there's extra propulsion right well
actually it would be great because what
you could do is uh is you could sort of
um since there's no gravity hopefully
that means that you could not have the
airway collapsing and snoring would be
less that's actually a really
interesting hypothesis one that I don't
know supect that most astronauts are so
so fit that they probably are not
snorers um great hypothesis I love it
there's the first grant um but yes so
you have to carabin yourself against
this sort of large cylindrical um metal
cigar that you're floating around and
that's the first thing the second weird
thing is that when you in sort of zero g
when you exhale if there wasn't
sufficient
circulation and you're strapped in and
you're in the same position what begins
to happen is you get this buildup this
cloud of carbon dioxide around you co22
bubble and it can obviously lead to a
very quick final popping you out of the
je pole just to be clear the space
station has air currents in it so it
would it would cycle through the air and
other than the CO2 coming out at body
temperature which is presumably warmer
than air temperature uh that it would
rise on Earth and not rise in the space
station so but so that's there is there
are air currents and so much so that if
you leave something if you let something
go it'll eventually go to the vent right
so that's why everything's velcroed in
um if you misplay something check the
vent check yeah so Matt you know talking
to the space station how many sunsets
and sunrises do you get in the space in
a in a 24-hour period for an astronaut
or on a space station and how are you
working with that here's the challenge
this is the main reason not the loss of
the gravitational Vector but the fact
that your circadian rhythm that we spoke
about is now thoroughly confused because
let's say that you're on the
International Space Station as as an
example um you are going to see every 24
hours 16 sunrises and 16 sunsets and so
your body is getting the signal that we
all get in a nice predictable fashion
once during the day once Sunrise once
Sunset it's getting the signal of okay
it's time to be awake um oh no now it's
it's Leep oh no and you're awake and no
no
no how connected are we to the sun we we
live in a fully lit nighttime I live in
New York City you know it it doesn't get
dark I I never take my eyes off my phone
so I mean I mean you know are we Farmers
no you know we're not all just up time
to go go to sleep the sun is s time to
wake up so do we think it really matters
anymore in modern society I'll still
give you the 24 hours but do you really
give a rat's ass about the sun
anymore you would think B I'm not sure I
heard you say that right give a rat's
ass about the sun take that song yeah
yeah well speaking speaking about um the
road and der a as you just described it
um I yes it does matter and in fact it's
part it's one of the contributing
reasons why there is so many um or
there's so much sleep disruption and
sleep problem um such a sleep problem
that we see in society right now we have
become dislocated from this natural
Edict of the rising and setting of the
sun we are a dark deprived Society in
this modern era and we need Darkness at
night in particular to help regulate the
hormone release called melatonin which
augments your human sleep and in part we
can do this with natural light when we
come in in the evenings no wonder where
are sleep disrupted because our brain is
thoroughly confused it's in constant
lowlevel light Matt I I might be a good
subject for your sleep studies because I
can sleep anytime anywhere in
practically any position for almost any
length of time so much so that I would
say you know the power nap that people
talk about yeah I I I can either have
that or not if I got a couple minutes I
I say let me sleep for 20 minutes and
I'll get up and go let me sleep for an
hour and a half let me sleep for 45 and
I'll do this and at night I can sleep
for eight hours or five hours depending
what I need to do in that day so and I
can go to sleep within minutes of laying
down down you know in in some kind of
comfortable position and I met so many
people that have a hard time sleeping I
said what do you mean you have a just go
to sleep right or stay awake and do
something productive don't lay in bed
say I can't get to sleep then go do
something mow the lawn I mean so so yeah
11:30 at night get the lawn mower out
your neighbors are going to love
you um am is it true that people who
sleep anytime anywhere and and I don't
drink coffee I don't have a relationship
with caffeine so I don't depend on that
for me to be awake or asleep is this I I
think that's unusual based on people I
speak to it is unusual and it's
especially unusual the older that you
get I'm not suggesting that you're old
but I'm an old fart I'm an old crusty
man right now so trust me I'm I'm right
there with you in the foothills of
middle age at least right now um it is
inbound what we what I would say is that
firstly you could just be one of those
unique people who have an incredible
appetite and hunger and drive for Sleep
such that the alacrity of your sleep
with which it arrives is stunning and
that you're in the top 1% the other
thing that sometimes we would want to do
however is check the quality of your
sleep because if you are constantly able
to fall asleep any time anywhere for any
duration which is what you just
described to me at that point I may be
getting a little bit worried that you're
carrying a lingering
Sleep Quality debt because there's
something about your sleep that may not
be quite sufficient such that with that
debt you are constantly craving your
brain has this constant hunger because
you are constantly in a fasted State as
it were when it comes to Quality sleep
so no wonder whenever you give your
brain the chance it thinks time to Feast
because my goodness I'm so sort of sleep
macronutrient deficient right it t or
could could have been that she just a
closet narcoleptic no I I mean so so but
also when I wake up I'm pretty perky
when I wake up I'm not one of the that's
right yeah and and there is
unfortunately there is not necessarily a
strong alignment between your subjective
sense of how well you slept last night
so I would say that when it comes to um
that sleep need we would just want to
check the quality of your sleep to make
sure that you're sleeping okay time put
me on electrodes okay I will bring you
in anytime we'll fly out we we'll come
and apply them tonight tell me where you
live and once I know where you live I'll
be
careful Matt this has been a delight
Neil degrass Tyson here coming from a
Star Talk special edition on sleep we'll
see you again provided you continue to
look
up
d